tagelanges campieren nur für ein paar
turnschuhe im berliner bezirk kreuzberg
trotzen auch als niederwetz bezeichnete
schuh fetischist dem grauen winterwetter
sie hoffen alle dass treter im design
der sitzbezüge der berliner
verkehrsbetriebe bvg zu ergattern
die bvg genau die die show mit dem kult
ist mir egal für furore gesorgt hat dann
öffnet der laden und bvg chefin sigrid
nikutta begrüßte kunden höchst
persönlich sie erläutert dass ganz
besonderes schmankerl des niger und man
beachte ihren schal ebenfalls im
sitzbezug muster unsere kunden ist der
große vorteil dass in dem ton schule
integriert eine jahre frage wenn sie den
turnschuhe tragen können sie ein jahr
lang kostenlos bus und bahn in berlin
180 euro kostet ein paar
die serie ist auf 500 stück limitiert in
der szene zahlen sammler dafür horrende
summen
andere freuen sich einfach nur über
bequeme schuhe und einen freibad bonus
die fahrscheine bitte ist mir egal
pardon ist doch von gestern ab jetzt
heißt es seit ihr eure füße zeigt her
eure schuh